im flüchtlingslager moria auf lesbos
brennt es erneut deutschland und
frankreich wollen 400 minderjährige
aufnehmen
die afrikanische schweinepest erreicht
brandenburg mit direkten folgen erste
länder verhängen ein importstopp für
deutsches schweinefleisch zum glück nur
eine übung beim ersten bundesweiten warm
tag zeigen sich erhebliche pannen
sirenen heulen ich die ware nap versagt
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen zum nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem donnerstag an meiner seite ist
für den sport kristin otto nun der
zukunft von sebastian vettel guten abend
das feuer im flüchtlingslager moria sei
gezielte brandstiftung gewesen sagt die
griechische regierung von asylbewerbern
als reaktion auf die korona quarantäne
tausende kinder frauen und männer sind
immer noch obdachlos und ohne nahrung
übergangsweise zelte aufzustellen stößt
auf widerstand der bevölkerung auf der
insel lesbos in der nähe des türkischen
festland gab es in der nacht neue feuer
in dem fast komplett zerstörten lager in
moria waren knapp 13.000 menschen
untergebracht
axel konrad berichtet und wieder flammen
in moria die zelte und baracken die das
erste feuer verschont hatte brender nun
auch lichterloh
also schnell zusammengerafft was
geblieben ist die kinder gepackt und
raus aus dem lager aber wo jetzt
schlafen wo essen hilfe erreicht
offenbar nur wenige organisation keine
hilfsorganisationen keine griechische
regierung niemand hilft uns 1000
flüchtlinge werden erst einmal hier
zuflucht finden auf dieser fähre die auf
der gegenüberliegenden seite der insel
fest gemacht hat und für diese
minderjährigen ohne eltern ist lesbos
ist moria erst einmal geschichte
400 von ihnen wurden mit flugzeugen in
den norden des landes gebracht
thessaloniki
die nächste station
oliseh auch sie fühlen sich allein
gelassen von der regierung von brüssel
anwohner blockieren die zufahrt zum camp
moria wollen verhindern dass neue
unterkünfte errichtet werden
dieses ganze flüchtlingsproblem vom
lager moore hat das dorf moria schultern
müssen deswegen sind wir hier heute und
wir werden niemals zurückweichen das
lager wird nicht wieder entstehen
es muss eine langfristige lösung
gefunden werden auch von europa denn es
sind nicht nur die flüchtlinge
griechenlands es sind die flüchtlinge
europas sie sind hier nicht mehr
willkommen und sie wollen ja auch nicht
mehr sein
über ihr schicksal aber entscheiden
andere nicht hier nicht in moria andreas
postel ist für uns vor ort wie erleben
sie die lage schaffen es die behörden
die menschen zu versorgen
ich stehe jetzt hier direkt auf der
hauptstrasse zwischen maria und dem
hafen und hier campieren tausende die
aus dem lager moria gekommen sind und
die auch heute nacht nicht wissen wo sie
unterkommen sollen frauen kinder die
hier an der straßenecke warten und
wahrscheinlich diese nacht hier auch
wieder im freien verbringen müssen
sie fühlen sich im stich gelassen es
gibt das wenigste es gibt kaum
trinkwasser kaum sanitäre einrichtungen
ein bisschen was zu essen die
griechischen behörden versuchen hier die
menschen mit dem nötigsten zu versorgen
aber auch medizinische versorgung gibt
es kaum
es heißt das in der in den nächsten
stunden ein schiff kommen soll aber das
weiß man nicht genau
das ziel der griechischen behörden ist
eigentlich die menschen hier auf lesbos
zu lassen
im gesicht hier der griechischen
tragödie von moria zeigt sich das
scheitern der europäischen
migrationspolitik aber um was es jetzt
hier in erster linie geht ist aktive
nothilfe für die menschen die jetzt
wieder eine nacht im freien campieren
müssen
eindrücke live von lesbos dankeschön
andreas postel wie helfen mehrere
bundesländer und kommunen haben
angeboten flüchtlinge aus lesbos
aufzunehmen
darauf drängen auch der csu
entwicklungsminister spd und teile der
cdu
doch innenminister seehofer lehnte das
bisher ab er will eine europäische
lösung
die bundeskanzlerin und der französische
präsident marco haben jetzt erste
zeichen gesetzt allerdings in sehr
begrenztem umfang
andrea maurer
für sie ist jetzt eine lösung gefunden
die rund 400 unbegleiteten
minderjährigen aus dem abgebrannten
lager in muri sollen auf deutschland
frankreich und andere eu länder verteilt
werden eine europäische lösung für die
flüchtlinge in griechenland ist das noch
nicht
in einem ersten schritt jetzt das
angebot an griechenland für die
minderjährigen flüchtlinge und es
müssten weitere schritte folgen für
gemeinsame verantwortung deutschland hat
sich dieser verantwortung gestellt aber
wir können nicht zufrieden sein mit
einer europäischen migrationspolitik die
gibt es im grunde heute so nicht die
innenpolitische debatte ob deutschland
auch im alleingang flüchtlinge aufnehmen
soll geht unterdessen weiter
innenminister seehofer hat sich bislang
nur über seinen sprecher geäußert er sei
weiter dagegen doch der druck auch aus
regierungsreihen wächst deshalb sollte
jetzt zur lösung des aktuellen
herausforderungen deutschland ein
zeichen der humanität setzen
2000 menschen aufnehmen das haben die
bundesländer angeboten und dazu
gleichzeitig alle anderen eu staaten
auffordern diesem guten beispiel der
humanität zu folgen
die afg sieht in einer aufnahme das
falsche signal und behauptet die
flüchtlinge seien selbst schuld an ihrer
lage
wenn wir die aufnehmen haben wir das
schlepper modell dass betrüger modell
das erpresser modell hierzu einfach die
baracken anderen werden wir überall
aufgenommen noch verschlimmert das darf
nicht sein
wir haben platz haben gestern
demonstranten in mehreren deutschen
städten gerufen sie meinten platz für
die menschen aus moriya bislang beharrt
der innenminister auf einer europäischen
lösung eine eu-weite verteilung von
tausenden flüchtlingen aus griechenland
aber ist alles andere als in sicht
angesichts steigender corona zahlen hat
die bundesregierung ihre reisewarnungen
ausgeweitet unter anderem auf korsika
und drei weitere regionen in frankreich
außerdem wird vor reisen nach prag und
genf gewarnt auch hierzulande steigt die
zahl der gemeldeten neuinfektionen im
schnitt der vergangenen sieben tage
haben sich 1219 90 menschen täglich
angesteckt gestern lag der schnitt bei
us präsident john hat lange versucht das
corona virus zu verharmlosen ein jetzt
veröffentlichtes interview zeigt er
kannte schon zu beginn der pandemie die
gravierenden risiken hat seine
landsleute aber bewusst im unklaren
gelassen
wie der präsident das rechtfertigt zeigt
ines trams rage wut das neue buch des
watergate journalisten bob woodward
bringt präsident tromp in bedrängnis
bewusst hat er die öffentlichkeit in die
irre geführt als die welt noch rätselte
wusste er bereits dass corona virus wird
durch die luft übertragen anfang februar
nannte er es in gesprächen mit woodward
tödliches zeug
das ist sehr knifflig sehr brenzlig es
ist auch tödlicher als eine heftige
grippe währenddessen redete trump in der
öffentlichkeit das risiko klein das
virus werde von allein verschwinden
wertvolle zeit verstrich stattdessen
wahlkampfveranstaltungen vor
menschenmengen ohne maske ich wollte es
immer herunterspielen ich spiele es noch
immer gern herunter weil ich keine panik
erzeugen möchte kurz nach
veröffentlichung der interviews
gegenoffensive tramper hätte im
interesse der menschen gehandelt
ich bin ein schier lieder für dieses
land ich liebe unser land und wollte
unseren bürgern keine angst machen ich
wollte keine panik schüren und das land
und die welt nicht in den wahnsinn
treiben
190.000 tote offen wie viele noch leben
könnten hätte trump nicht verharmlost
sondern entsprechende maßnahmen
ergriffen
der vorwurf seines kontrahenten trump
wollte seine wiederwahl retten nicht
menschenleben
er wusste um die gefahr und als die
tödliche krankheit unsere nation zerriss
hat er seinen job nicht gemacht mit
absicht das ist verrat am amerikanischen
volk auf leben und tod amerika hat die
pandemie noch immer nicht unter
kontrolle
nun ist klar es war nicht nur schlechtes
krisenmanagement sondern volle absicht
des präsidenten die gefahr zu ignorieren
die belarussische oppositionspolitikerin
kohlessen koffer hat nach ihrer
entführung strafanzeige gegen die
behörden gestellt
die beamten hätten versucht sie unter
morddrohungen in die ukraine
abgeschrieben schreibt die 38 jährige
lebendig oder zerstückelt kulissen
koffer soll am montag in einen minibus
gezerrt worden sein
ihre abschiebung konnte sie verhindern
seitdem sitzt sie in minsk in
untersuchungshaft
zurück nach deutschland mit spannung
wurde heute auf die steuerschätzung
geblickt ein kassensturz in der korona
krise und der es ernüchternd
die steuereinnahmen sind sehr viel
niedriger als erwartet nach schätzungen
der bundesregierung wird das
vorkrisenniveau erst 2022 wieder
erreicht sein
patricia wiedemeier hat die details auch
wenn die korona krise weiterhin für
geringere steuereinnahmen sorgt der
finanzminister gibt sich optimistisch
ganz so schlimm wie noch im frühjahr
vorhergesagt sei es nun doch nicht
gekommen
im augenblick spricht vieles dafür es
geht wieder aufwärts
die jüngsten zahlen der
gesamtwirtschaftlichen entwicklung
zeigen dass wir das schlimmste wohl
hinter uns haben
dennoch ist werden dieses jahr etwa 80
milliarden weniger sein nahmen bund
länder und gemeinden im letzten jahr
noch insgesamt 799 milliarden euro an
steuern ein
sind es dieses jahr prognostiziert etwa
718 und 773 im nächsten jahr
der deutsche städtetag fordert weitere
hilfen des bundes auch für die nächsten
zwei jahre
da ihnen gewerbe einnahmen wegbrechen
die zahlen der steuerschätzung bedeuten
dass wir in den städten vor zwei harten
jahren stehen wir haben
investitionsbedarf in höhe von rund 140
milliarden da geht es um den verkehr da
geht es vor allem um schulen
da geht es um kitas auch grüne und linke
fordern weitere investitionen 500
milliarden für die nächsten zehn jahre
eine investitionspaket das in die
zukunft investiert und nicht in die
vergangenheit und deshalb auf
klimaschutz neue technologien
digitalisierung setzt jeder der jetzt
schon wieder anfängt über die schwarze
null zu reden ist auf einem völlig
falschen weg
der finanzminister jedenfalls redet
nicht davon für ihn ist klar auch im
nächsten jahr wird eine hohe
neuverschuldung nötig seien
mitten in der korona pandemie müssen wir
uns jetzt auch noch mit der
afrikanischen schweinepest beschäftigen
in nachbarländern basiert sie schon
länger nun hat sie auch deutschland
erreicht die tierseuche wurde bei einem
toten wildschwein in brandenburg nach
gewesen
für menschen ist die schweinepest
ungefährlich für schweine tödlich thomas
konto hat die wichtigsten fakten die
afrikanische schweinepest ist eine
schwere virusinfektion sie befällt nur
wild und zucht schweine 2007 wurde die
solche von afrika nach georgien
eingeschleppt und verbreitet sich vor
allem über russland und das baltikum auf
den menschen springt sie nicht über
unbedenklich sind der verzehr von
schweinefleisch und der kontakt zum tier
also menschen erkranken nicht an
afrikanische schweinepest aber sie
verbreiten den langlebigen erreger er
haftet an kleidung an den reifen von
fahrzeugen und an speiseabfällen
infizieren sich schweine dann ist es zu
spät wenn es gibt keinen impfstoff der
die krankheit verhindert und die
verläuft nahezu immer tödlich
schweinebauern in ganz deutschland
fürchten jetzt schwere wirtschaftliche
folgen wenn sie ihr fleisch nicht mehr
ins ausland exportieren dürfen
gefunden wurde das tote wildschwein in
schenkendöbern nahe der polnischen
grenze das gebiet 15 kilometer rund um
den fundort geht jetzt als gefahrenzone
inklusive jagd und ernte verbot
zusätzlich soll es eine drei kilometer
sperrzone geben die eingezahlt wird und
nicht betreten werden darf
mehr von jan meyer und nicola albrecht
der fundort des infizierten wildschweins
im brandenburgischen schenkendöbern hier
an der deutsch polnischen grenze ist nun
schnelles handeln gefragt damit aus der
krise keine katastrophe wird fordert
solchen experte thomas mettenleiter
wichtig ist es jetzt sehr schnell dass
infizierte gebiet festzustellen
das heißt festzustellen ob das ein
einzelfall ist oder ob sich die
infektion schon ausgebreitet hat und
dann dieses infizierte gebiet
einzugrenzen abriegeln sowie sperre und
pufferzonen im radius von bis zu 30
kilometern errichten ordnet die
landesregierung an beginnen könne man
allerdings erst kommenden montag
personalmangel heißt es die landwirte in
ganz deutschland rechnen seit jahren mit
dieser nachricht auch cord meyer aus
niedersachsen er habe wie die meisten
bauern vorgesorgt und könne seine
schweine durch zäune und hygiene
konzepte schützen und trotzdem fürchtet
er gravierende wirtschaftliche verluste
in konsequenz kann es bedeuten dass der
markt zusammenbricht
also die preise noch weiter in richtung
1 euro 1 euro 30 gehen von 1 eur 47 und
die wirtschaftlichkeit nicht mehr
gegeben ist auch die
bundeslandwirtschaftsministerin ist
alarmiert harnik mache will sie jedoch
verhindern und betont dass die exporte
innerhalb der eu gesichert sein
das problem regional bekämpfbar was
heißt das konkret dass der handel nur
für die im einzurichtenden restriktion
gebiet liegenden betriebe eingeschränkt
wird doch deutschland ist einer der
grössten schweinefleisch exporteure
weltweit asien der größte markt und
südkorea hat umgehend ein importverbot
für deutsches schweinefleisch verhängt
denn noch wichtigere abnehmer china hat
sich noch nicht geäußert es steht viel
auf dem spiel in brandenburg lässt man
sich aber offenbar zeit einige werden
sich an die zeit des kalten krieges
erinnern als regelmäßig testweise die
sirenen heulten heute gab es zum ersten
mal seit 30 jahren wieder einen
bundesweiten probealarm heute vormittag
um 11 heulten die sirenen aber schnell
wird klar nicht überall
zum glück war es nur eine übung denn
auch die amtlichen war apps zeigten
macken über den deutschen bank berichtet
dominik mühl rosin
so sollte es heute überall klingen um 11
uhr in deutschland sirenen im programm
außerdem warnungen auch auf den wahn
apps nina und kathrin wenn sie denn
funktionierten
das ziel zum einen die verbreitungswege
sollten technisch erprobt werden zum
zweiten wollen wir eben die menschen
tatsächlich ein stück weit
sensibilisieren achtung
herausforderungen wachsen ihr müsst euch
ein stück weit vorbereiten
dazu gehört eben auch die befassung mit
der thematik doch vielerorts
verwunderung es bleibt still
in münchen etwa der grund hier sind alle
serien längst abgebaut und auch auf den
eps zahlreiche probleme
die gefahrenmeldung kommt teilweise gar
nicht teilweise mit großer verzögerung
auf den smartphones an verwirrung bei
den nutzern
ich habe zwei verschiedenen städte da
angegeben und ich bin über einen
aufstand informiert worden
es wäre schon gut die technik
funktionieren würde damit wir auch als
menschen dann darauf reagieren können
das verantwortliche bundesamt für
bevölkerungsschutz und katastrophenhilfe
räumt am nachmittag ein dass die
absprachen nicht funktioniert hätten zu
viele leitstellen hätten gleichzeitig
alarm ausgelöst dadurch sei es zu einer
überlastung des systems gekommen
das bundesinnenministerium spricht gar
von einem fehlschlag und erklärt die
vorgänge werden jetzt umfassend
aufgearbeitet die gewonnenen
erkenntnisse werden bei der weiteren
entwicklung des warnsystems
berücksichtigt besser abstimmen wollen
sich die behörden künftig damit im
ernstfall alle waren systeme
funktionieren
die behörden an der westküste der usa
sind in größter sorge
durch die hitzewelle breiten sich die
verheerenden waldbrände massiv aus die
feuer wüten inzwischen in drei
bundesstaaten kalifornien oregon und
washington
mehrere menschen starben in den flammen
und es wird mit weiteren opfern
gerechnet da einige gebiete
abgeschnitten sind
san francisco ist eingehüllt von dichtem
rauch der himmel ist dunkel orange ist
wird nicht mehr richtig hell hat er
schnitt jetzt nach venedig seit einer
guten woche laufen dort zum 77 mal die
filmfestspiele
heute steigt ein deutscher beitrag 1 ins
rennen um den goldenen löwen ein
politthriller brandaktuell von
regisseurin julia von heinz über ihr
werk und das erste große filmfest in
corona 2
berichtet annette hilsenbeck das erste
mal auf dem roten teppich in venedig und
die deutschen stars versprühen einen
hauch glamour opfern corona bedingt
keine fans jubeln die regisseurin julia
von heinz ist als eine von acht frauen
den wettbewerb um den goldenen löwen
vertreten so viele wie noch nie und das
mit an polit dennoch diese ordnung zu
beseitigen und morgen die ganze
diskussion studentin lisa von rechts
zurück in deutschland geschockt will
nicht tatenlos zusehen
in dieser findet projekt hier wirklich
toll und ich würd gern teil davon sein
sie schließt sich einer linken antifa
gruppe an die zunächst friedlich gegen
rechts protestiert doch ein teil der
gruppe radikalisiert sich auch luisa
findet gewalt zunehmend legitim
es ist absoluter schwachsinn der
stärkung der rechten politische
radikalisierung mit gewalt ein aktuelles
thema erstaunlich und damit haben wir
selber nicht gerechnet ich habe den film
vor 20 jahren beginnt begonnen zu
entwickeln so ungefähr vor fünf jahren
habe ich gemerkt jetzt jetzt kommt die
zeit
lisa und ihre gruppe schlagen zunehmend
zu gegen rechts bis zu einer fatalen
aktion rechte gewalt gegen gewalt
rechtfertigt die regisseurin will da
gedanklich und emotional herausfordern
gewalt darf und soll nicht ein mittel
sein
aber wer es jetzt nicht doch richtig es
kann doch nicht sein dass die anderen
jetzt siegen und dass das das ende des
films sein soll das heißt ich versuche
wir versuchen den zuschauer immer wieder
in einen zwiespalt zu bringen stellung
beziehen sich engagieren bis zu welcher
grenze
es ist ein herausfordernder deutscher
film bei den filmfestspielen in venedig
damit sind wir beim sport sebastian
vettel bleibt der formel 1 erhalten
christine etwas neues bei ferrari ist
zwar bald schluss aber dann folgt ein
aufregendes projekt so sebastian vettel
zu seiner zukunft bei aston martin
der viermalige weltmeister unterschrieb
einen vertrag ab 2021 noch startet der
rennstall unter dem namen racing point
nach zahllosen pleiten in seiner
sechsten ferrari saison peter sebastian
vettel wieder formel eins morgenluft
was ich jetzt entschieden habe ist das
beste für mich und ich freue mich schon
darauf das zu beweisen
nachdem ferrari im mai die trennung von
vettel verkündet hatte war es nur noch
abwärts gegangen für das stolze team und
den 33 jährigen zuletzt in monza nur
startplatz 17
er war sogar nah dran seine karriere zu
beenden
kloos na ich weiß nicht ob es eine skala
für nach gibt aber es waren
ich musste abwägen was das beste für
mich ist ab der nächsten saison wird es
aston martin sein der designierte
nachfolger rennstall von racing point
zuletzt in monza mit lance stroll auf
rang drei vettel wird das cockpit von
sergio perez übernehmen und zum radsport
zwölfte etappe der tour de france mit
218 km die längste dieser rundfahrt
rein ins zentralmassiv und mit einem
tagessieger der erstmalig ein teilstück
gewinnt im markt herrsche aus der
schweiz nach einem eindrucksvollen
alleingang maximilian schach man trägt
die hoffnungen seiner mannschaft auf den
etappensieg im hügeligen finale
doch gegen diesen antritt von marc
hirschi ist auch er machtlos
schon zwei mal knapp geschlagen bei
dieser tour wie der 22 jahre alte
schweizer heute endlich ganz vorn landen
fachmann unter spanier soll er die
ersten verfolger
aber der rückstand zum überragend
fahrenden hirschi wächst markierte aus
der schweiz darf seinen ersten
etappenerfolg genießen und mit ihm sein
in deutschland lizensierte steam sunweb
schach man dagegen wird als sechster für
seine anstrengungen nicht belohnt
[Musik]
in der verfassung und der verdiente
sieger dieser etappe die am
gesamtklassement nichts wesentliches
ändert vielleicht morgen der wird es
knackig sieben bergwertungen aber
zumindest das wetter wird gut es bleibt
nämlich ruhig und waren die details hat
gleich osten telli claus kleber begrüßt
sie um viertel vor zehn im heute-journal
hier ist morgen wieder christian sieh
was dran
danke für ihr interesse ich wünsche
ihnen noch einen schönen abend und sagt
auf wiedersehen